tallas de rostros cuchillos de piedra
vasijas de cerámica conocidas como
querés después de siglos bajo tierra
regresaron a la superficie del siglo 21
para arrojar luz sobre la civilización
tiwanakota y esta semana por primera vez
se presentaron al público
arqueólogos bolivianos las descubrieron
en 2019 enterradas a 30 centímetros en
la ciudadela prehispánica de tiahuanaco
el material que es importado ahora y el
contexto la información que está
asociada es muy importante para poder ir
avanzando en el conocimiento de del
inicio
[Música]
de la entidad política activa na
las piezas 45 en total seguramente
tienen un significado ritual ya que
fueron halladas en un templo de la
ciudadela y científicos y autoridades
esperan que sirvan para conocer mejor la
civilización tiahuanacota estos
hallazgos para nosotros
nuevamente nos hacen aterrizar
es un cable a tierra
para volver a ver la realidad de donde
somos
como habíamos sido y más importante
explicar muchas de las cosas de cómo son
hoy
el imperio tiahuanaco se considera uno
de los más longevos de américa del sur
con 2.500 años de historia en el siglo 8
después de cristo se extendió por la
cordillera andina y llegó a ocupar parte
de bolivia chile y perú pero desapareció
después del siglo 12
el porqué de su declive no se sabe cómo
gran parte del pasado prehispánico de
américa latina'